[Música]
y
continúan los esfuerzos por evacuar
civiles atrapados en la acería de as
hostal y de la ciudad de mariupol el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
denunció que los rusos están
bombardeando la fábrica pero moscú lo
niega y dice que los corredores
humanitarios están abiertos
'francia insumisa y los socialistas
franceses cerraron una alianza histórica
para impedir que el presidente de manuel
ma home se quede con las mayorías en el
parlamento de cara a las elecciones
mientras que el partido del mandatario
se alió con colectivos de centro y
cambio de nombre
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador comenzó su primera gira
oficial por el exterior el mandatario
está en guatemala y luego irá a el
salvador y honduras
la migración es el tema central tenemos
reportes desde ciudad de guatemala
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y
comenzamos con la actualidad ucraniana
el presidente voló de mil selenski
confirmó que siguen los esfuerzos por
evacuar a cientos de civiles que están
atrincherados en la siderúrgica de as
hostal en la ciudad portuaria de
mariupol aunque no confirmó cuántas
personas están intentando sacar de allí
en esta tercera operación también
participan la onu y la cruz roja
internacional imágenes publicadas por el
ministerio del interior de la provincia
de donges que muestran explosiones sobre
la acería mientras que el regimiento a
soft que está dentro de la planta acusa
a rusia de bombardear los violando así
la tregua para evacuar a civiles sin
embargo moscú lo niega y dice que los
corredores humanitarios siguen abiertos
a las dos partes del conflicto habían
declarado una breve ventana de silencio
o un alto el fuego donde logramos
evacuar ahora regresamos con los civiles
con nosotros
lo hacemos espero que esta operación
continúe y que podamos evacuar a otro
número de civiles que quisieran
abandonar las áreas de combate
intensificado hacia lugares seguros en
sabori allá y más allá
en medio de los ataques ucrania busca
financiación hoy el presidente volodymyr
se les lanzó una plataforma llamada
united plan y fort unidos 24 en inglés
para recaudar donaciones además en la
capital polaca varsovia se realizó una
conferencia de donantes en la que
recolectaron 6.500 millones de dólares
para ayudar a ucrania
kiev sigue pidiendo ayuda y europa
responderá en la conferencia
internacional de donantes de varsovia el
jueves el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski hizo una aparición virtual
pidiendo más asistencia económica 2 está
funcionando de recursos necesitamos
suficientes recursos económicos para que
los hombres y las mujeres de ucrania
puedan estar provistos de los
suficientes recursos que necesiten
mientras la guerra continúa el estado
ucraniano como administrador de estos
cubrirá todas las necesidades urgentes
en defensa y ayuda humanitaria y
humanitaria por el momento ya han
surgido resultados inmediatos del
proceso elogiado por los líderes
europeos
en esta conferencia fuimos capaces de
reunir más de 6 mil millones de euros y
este dinero será distribuido para apoyar
a ucrania y todos aquellos que apoyan a
ucrania porque sabemos cuán doloroso y
costoso está siendo para la nación
ucraniana we know how
it for you crying in nation entre los
países que aumentaron su asistencia se
incluyen finlandia república checa
croacia
quien amplió su ayuda anual a ucrania en
300 millones de euros para el presidente
del consejo europeo charles michel
podría ser la plataforma de lanzamiento
para una futura recuperación completa
queremos estar operativos y este
encuentro y la decisión que salga hoy en
mi opinión debe ser un punto de partida
para un plan marshall europeo para
ucrania
esto significa que ayudará a ucrania y
ayudaremos a la gente de ucrania
el encuentro llega cuando zelinski
intenta ganar tiempo en la esfera global
para facilitar la asistencia financiera
el jueves su gobierno también lanzó una
plataforma de crowdfunding global
llamada united twenty ford todas las
donaciones serán transferidas al banco
de ucrania y asignadas a los ministerios
más importantes del país en otras
noticias de europa la izquierda francesa
logró un pacto histórico los socialistas
se sumaron a la coalición que lidera
francia insumisa y en la que también
están los ecologistas y los comunistas
aunque tenían diferencias sobre la
relación con la unión europea finalmente
se aliaron para que emanuel bach o no en
las mayo con las mayorías en las
elecciones legislativas
por su parte del partido oficialista
república en marcha se unió con los
centristas módem y oryzon en un intento
por no perder los comicios y cambió su
nombre a penas en su renacimiento
solo sonrisas entre los negociadores del
partido socialista por el acuerdo
francia en su misa el histórico pacto es
un intento de impedir que el presidente
manuel marco obtenga la mayoría en el
parlamento pero el acuerdo podría
provocar la implosión de uno de los
partidos tradicionales de francia ante
las críticas de antiguos dirigentes el
secretario del partido lo defendió no me
he convertido repentinamente en la frase
insumisa lo que pienso lo seguiré
pensando sería una completa locura pasar
de esto y pensar que porque tenemos
desacuerdos no podemos gobernar juntos
pienso exactamente lo contrario
según olivia fue esta unión es la única
forma de salvar el partido uno que lleva
casi una década en un espiral
descendente desde la victoria de
françois hollande en 2012 hasta el 17 de
anne hidalgo sólo han pasado 10 años
hidalgo ha criticado el acuerdo pero ha
dicho que no quiere interponerse en su
camino para otras figuras del partido la
unión es impensable ni françois hollande
ni su ex primer ministro bernat castell
respaldan el acuerdo uno de los
principales puntos de fricción era
europa el partido socialista o apartarse
temporalmente de las normas de la unión
europea mientras que francia en su misa
dice estar dispuesta a desobedecer las
el acuerdo ofrece 70 escaños al partido
socialista con la esperanza de ganar
unos 30 ya cerraron las urnas en
reinounido para las elecciones
municipales aunque las votaciones son en
inglaterra escocia gales e irlanda del
norte estas últimas son las más
llamativas y es que los norirlandeses
elegirán una nueva asamblea la novedad
es que el nacionalista sinn fein por
primera vez podría tener más escaños que
su rival más cercano el partido
unionista democrático que estaba a favor
de la pertenencia británica si sinn fein
gana marcaría un cambio histórico pues
es un partido que quiere abandonar el
reino unido- 24 años después del acuerdo
de paz del viernes santo los resultados
se conocerán a partir de las 2 de la
mañana -hora local-
por ahora repasemos la historia de
irlanda del norte
10 de abril de 1998 el acuerdo del
viernes santo- pone fin al conflicto en
irlanda del norte
los enfrentamientos entre los unionistas
protestantes junto al ejército británico
por un lado y los republicanos católicos
por otros se sucedieron durante tres
décadas un conflicto territorial y
religioso que tiene sus raíces en la
partición de irlanda en 1921 cuando seis
condados del norte de la isla
permanecieron dentro del reino unido- en
la actualidad los dos millones de
habitantes de irlanda del norte están
divididos casi a partes iguales entre
católicos y protestantes el 30 de enero
de 1972 sucedió el domingo sangriento
cuando los soldados británicos abrieron
fuego contra una manifestación en derry
matando a 14 personas convirtiéndose en
un símbolo de la causa republicana
norirlandesa el ir a el ejército
republicano irlandés se embarcó entonces
en un ciclo de violencia y ataques como
sus enemigos unionistas no fue hasta los
acuerdos de 1998 cuando el sinn fein la
rama política del irá comenzó a jugar el
juego democrático dentro de la nueva
asamblea de belfast en 2005 el ira
acabaría abandonando oficialmente las
armas
dos años después junto al partido
unionista democrático dup el sinn fein
participó por primera vez en el
ejecutivo de irlanda del norte en la
persona del antiguo líder del ira martin
mcguinness los partidarios del
permanecer dentro del reino unido han
sido la primera fuerza política hasta
2022 pero el break sheet ha socavado
esta nueva paz porque el acuerdo del
viernes santo- prohíbe cualquier
frontera física entre irlanda e irlanda
del norte y con el presi se puso en duda
los europeos prevén el control aduanero
de las mercancías que pasan entre
irlanda del norte y el resto del reino
unido un protocolo que ha sido muy
criticado por londres y los unionistas
hasta el día de hoy y que ha provocado
graves trastornos de la cadena de
suministros de irlanda del norte los
precios se dispararon y la sensación de
estar abandonados creció entre la
población en la primavera de 2021 los
barrios protestantes estaban en llamas y
hubo enfrentamientos entre algunos
jóvenes y la policía una señal de que el
conflicto sigue vivo en la mente de la
gente en belfast los muros sirven
separando a los republicanos católicos y
a los unionistas protestantes
al menos tres personas murieron y dos
más cuidados quedaron heridas en un
ataque en el centro de israel la policía
asegura que fue perpetrado por
palestinos testigos y socorristas
afirmaron que los atacantes usaron
hachas las autoridades instalaron
barricadas para intentar atrapar a los
sospechosos que huyeron del lugar estos
hechos ocurrieron en la ciudad de eilat
en medio de las celebraciones por la
creación del estado judío aunque para
los palestinos marca la nakba o
catástrofe pues más de 700.000 personas
huyeron y fueron expulsadas durante la
guerra de 1948
la violencia de las bandas criminales en
haití ya deja 39 civiles muertos según
protección civil el organismo agregó hoy
que los enfrentamientos entre las
pandillas 400 magos y chen merchán
obligaron a cerca de 9 mil personas a
abandonar sus domicilios ante esta
situación y la crisis económica cientos
de haitianos intentan llegar a estados
unidos de hecho han abarrotado los
centros de atención a migrantes de la
frontera norte de méxico su aspiración
es que acepten sus solicitudes de
refugio cuando expire la ley
estadounidense del título 42 que
limitaba el paso para reducir el cob y
19 esta es la situación en méxico hemos
recibido de recibido desde luego más
personas en estos días ha habido un
incremento que hemos detectado tanto
desde esta oficina como en los mismos
espacios sanitarios es decir los
albergues este espacio de acogida
tenemos muchas personas de distintas
nacionalidades incrementado la población
que arriba
de nacionalidad haitiana y lo que buscan
es
algunos buscan albergue algunos buscan
acogida algunos inclusive que acaban de
sedes agotaron los recursos y ahora se
acercan a buscar a ver dónde se pueden
quedar de hecho la migración es el tema
central de la gira que está haciendo el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador por el triángulo norte de
centroamérica el mandatario inició su
viaje en guatemala donde se reunirá con
su homólogo alejandro giammatei los
temas centrales serán la seguridad y la
migración como lo habíamos dicho luego
viajará a el salvador y honduras además
visitar a belice y cuba vamos entonces a
ciudad de guatemala donde está nuestro
corresponsal andrés suárez andrés
bienvenidos esta es la primera gira
oficial al exterior que realiza a lópez
obrador desde que asumió la presidencia
en diciembre de 2018 explíquenos por qué
se concentra en centroamérica y cuáles
son los objetivos
efectivamente maría clara es la primera
gira internacional del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
aunque ya había realizado tres viajes al
extranjero en tres oportunidades a eeuu
pero en esta oportunidad y como lo dijo
su canciller marcelo ebrard el sur es el
nuevo lugar y esta es la política la
apuesta de andrés manuel lópez obrador
en centroamérica en materia de seguridad
fronteriza y de frenar el programa y de
presentar programas para frenar la
migración sobre todo porque este
fenómeno se está incrementando conforme
va decreciendo la pandemia en eeuu por
ejemplo la frontera sur ya cruzaron más
de un millón
migrantes irregulares de que comenzó el
último año y aquí en ciudad de guatemala
ya arribó el presidente mexicano con su
comitiva del canciller marcelo ebrard
y secretarios de seguridad y de defensa
su esposa y en unos minutos en cualquier
momento arribarán a mis espaldas al
palacio nacional donde se encontrará con
el presidente llama 'the para justamente
hablar de estos temas de programas
migratorios seguridad fronteriza entre
otros porque también abrirán un nuevo
consulado mexicano una interconexión
ferroviaria y programas para que la
frontera de guatemala con méxico sea
mucho más amable nuevos cursos
fronterizos de entre otras y cuál es el
impacto de la gira para eeuu
bueno es un mensaje claro a los eeuu
porque hay varios antecedentes la
llamada por ejemplo de joe biden con
amlo enviar recientes también la visita
que hizo marcelo ebrard a washington
donde quedó claro la diferencia de
enfoque migratorio que tienen los dos
países porque mientras eeuu dice que hay
que reforzar las fronteras méxico no
méxico propone abrir las fronteras pero
con programas de oportunidades de empleo
y son esos programas abanderados de amlo
en centroamérica que se llaman sembrando
vidas o jóvenes construyendo futuro
donde por ejemplo hay más de 20.000
personas
reforestando diferentes son las verdes
fronterizas sin embargo hay varios
críticos que dicen que esta
reforestación críticos ambientales no se
está dando propiamente con con árboles
nativos pero entonces es un mensaje
claro a los eeuu de cara a la cumbre de
las américas de que se embolsilla el
dinero prometido los más de 4 mil
millones de dólares que la
administración byte de navidad' y un
inicio que están congeladas en el
congreso de los eeuu mientras en méxico
si lo está haciendo y así esto es lo que
está proponiendo andrés manuel lópez
obrador en su gira por centralmente
gracias a andrés suárez por la
información en otras noticias el jefe de
narcotraficante colombiano dayro antonio
úsuga alias otoniel se declaró no
culpable en eeuu mientras que la
justicia de ese país ordenó su detención
en nueva york a la espera del juicio el
líder de la banda criminal clan del
golfo fue extraditado por el gobierno
colombiano el fiscal federal
estadounidense bryon peace en brooklyn
nueva york lo pidió en extradición por
haber coordinado más de 40 envíos de
cocaína a suelo estadounidense cada uno
de más de una tonelada
hasta que las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]